the most transparent Administration in
history wants to keep you in the dark
about car-lago the White House and the
doj reportedly had a shared
understanding on how to keep Joe's
classified document Scandal tucked away
from the American people that is until
the media blew their cover and Biden
taking a page out of the waters Playbook
trying to pin the blame on his assistant
sorry Johnny an anonymous source leaking
to The Washington Post that the
president's longtime executive secretary
may have inadvertently mishandled the
documents setting off this growing
scandal
and now President Biden getting
frustrated with his friends in the
liberal press over his little garage
shop of classified Horrors I think
you're going to find there's nothing
there I have no regrets I'm following
what the lawyers have told me they want
me to do it's exactly what we're doing
there's no there there
and while Biden doesn't care he
apparently thinks the American people
are with him
I will answer the question but here's
the deal
you know what quite frankly bugs me is
that we have serious problem here we're
talking about
we're talking about what's going on and
the American people don't quite
understand why you don't ask me
questions about that
Secretary of stonewalling herself Karen
Jean-Pierre capping off a week of giving
non-answers on the Scandal
you heard him speak to it when he was
asked by your colleagues yesterday when
he was traveling in California I would
refer you to the White House Council
Office what does the president mean when
he said no regrets so I'm not going to
comment further from what the president
has said light on was he referring to
sort of the rollout of the information
or about the timeline totally understand
why you may want Clarity here but I'm
going to be prudent I'm going to be
consistent here I'm not going to comment
on um on on the ongoing process
what struck me Jessica was watching
Biden
dance around answering that question and
then lurking in the background was none
other than Gavin Newsom twiddling his
thumbs you pick up on that I hadn't but
excellent objects for the uh
the beautiful haired man from California
um
this was not a great statement about
this
um saying I have no regrets is not true
right everyone if you're if you have a
special counsel you regret something
right I'm sure that even former
president Trump would in his most honest
moment say
I would prefer it if I didn't have a
special account sessions I never should
have important sessions but this thing
about the people don't care about it
right or ask me questions they care
about it's the public that decides what
they care about and that's what happens
in elections right there are always
issues that either side are saying this
is going to be the the most important
election issue right the Republicans
thought that the border right inflation
in the Border we're gonna be the most
important things and the Democrats
thought that inflation and abortion the
jobs decision we're gonna be the most
important things and end up with the
Democrats gambled correctly on that and
the Republicans didn't and that's why we
had the result that we did but we do
have proof that over 70 of Americans do
think it's a serious issue and when you
don't lead with empathy and some
acknowledgment of the fact that people
who are not supporters but people who
are supporters of yours would be
disappointed that this would happen even
if they think there is no ill intent and
I haven't spoken to anyone at least on
the Democratic side who thinks that this
was intentional like he's hoarding
classified documents so he can sell them
to the Chinese or whatever you might
think Jesse acknowledge that people are
disappointed in you it'll make them a
lot more amenable to whatever comes out
in the end and I I hope that this ends
up being nothing the special counsel
says that it was a mistake
no problem moving on whatever it is but
you have to lead with something better
than I have no regrets over something
that got you he didn't need to sell them
to the Chinese
who's making enough money from the
Chinese sorry I thank you for helping me
fill in this judge when someone says
there's no there there what runs through
your mind well it reminds me of every
defendant I've ever prosecuted there's
no there there you know I wish I wish
you know we had said something different
but there really is no there there is
what Jessica just said here's what's
there Mike Davis wrote a great article
in Newsweek and he talks about theft
being a federal offense I think it's
section 793 of the federal code and he
talks about the fact that this is you
know blame your secretary give me a
break okay that's like a guy having an
affair okay we want to do it now a guy
having an affair with the secretary says
to his wife it's the secretary's fault
it wasn't my fault but here's here's the
thing about these classified documents
as I've said he had no right to them he
was not president he could not
declassify them as I said yesterday and
you puputed he left office in January of
2017 those documents weren't moved until
January of 2018 a year later so we've
got them moving from the White House to
somewhere and then to the Penn Biden
Center funded by the Chinese his son has
made Millions from the Chinese the same
son who's complained about having to pay
for his father's bills and paying him
fifty thousand dollars a month which
apparently according to Miranda Devine
is the same amount of money he got from
China and one of his deals okay and in
addition to that
Trump could declassify this guy can and
then they say well Vice President Biden
you know even though he couldn't
declassify he had Secret Service that's
nonsense the vice president does not
have Secret Service protection those
articles and those those files were not
in Secret Service protection so spare me
there's nothing there there there's a
lot there and we have to get to the
bottom so the White House always says we
want an independent Department of
Justice
and you find out that they were
colluding to keep this thing under wraps
yeah well let's let's just break it down
because I I couldn't help but giggle oh
first of all I'm really offended I have
a white hat on and the two of you that's
just selfish with your quite close but
um I clearly put out an email I put out
an email that I was wearing a white hat
it's ridiculous Jesse Kate thank you
Katie thank you guys for respecting me
yeah but
he forgot what he was talking about when
he got upset he was like uh really bugs
me when we're supposed to be talking
about that
that important thing that the American
people want us to be talking about that
important thing he forgot he got upset
and apparently whatever movie he watched
there's no regret and there's no there
there those are both closing statements
from the ends of movies so he's
completely lost and completely
frustrated and he would be because these
documents are six years old they've
already been used Hunter's already used
them he's already got the money for him
he just like the laptop like the child
and the pistol he puts things away
horribly that he tries to hide yeah it's
all laid out you look at it the there
there is Hunter is horrible at getting
rid of evidence and and if this was so
inadvertent and it was just a packing
mishap then why is one of the classified
documents at the president's desk at
home yeah look he can't say the
president can't say that he has regrets
because that would be an admission of
some kind of wrongdoing or guilt in the
situation and his lawyer is a very
clearly told him do not say any of that
because you're under criminal
investigation and as the judge said when
you have these documents you were
illegally in possession of them because
you weren't the president who had
Declassified them people do care about
this issue and they care about double
standards and they care about hypocrisy
Joe Biden's one who set the the standard
at the beginning of his administration
two years ago saying we're going to be
the most transparent I'm going to take
responsibility for things that happen in
my Administration now he's blaming other
people for for the situation as if you
know they are the ones responsible and
doesn't stop start with him the bottom
line is that we need to know why he had
the documents we still don't really know
why the search started coming up and all
these different places but we didn't
know why he had them was he using them
to write a book was he using them with
Hunter Biden who was a business partner
all this tiptoeing around that they
weren't business partners is garbage
they totally were business partners it's
in the emails from Hunter Biden's laptop
were they being used classroom
information to make these foreign
business dealings we don't know yet but
it's very clear the white house isn't
going to be answering questions again
today when there's a tough news cycle
they roll out John Kirby to answer a
bunch of questions on a foreign policy
issue so they can cut the time off of
Korean Jean-Pierre because she's
handling the situation so poorly and the
American people still don't have any
answers about why President Biden as the
vice president had this classified
information sitting in his garage while
the White House continues to say they
don't have a visitor log but clearly
there are plenty of visitors and to
Tyrese's Point Hunter Biden's criminal
record does not bode well for that
information being used properly well I
think we can all agree that Corrine
Jean-Pierre is going to have a stiff
drink tonight maybe three hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else